[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
méxico sigue esperando la verdad en el
caso de ayotzinapa se cumplen 7 años
desde la desaparición de los 43
estudiantes de la normal en iguala la
nueva hipótesis de lo sucedido está aún
sin confirmar reconstruimos lo que pasó
y el canadiense josh intruso hizo una
costosa apuesta convocó a elecciones
anticipadas sólo para terminar
exactamente en el mismo lugar en el que
estaba sigue siendo el primer ministro
pero sin la mayoría en el parlamento
pero gastó millones de dólares para
hacerlo y hay una polémica en perú por
un discurso del primer ministro guido
bellido en el congreso en quechua la
intérprete en lenguaje de señas resumió
muy brevemente pero no reflejó lo que he
venido había dicho a los pueblos
originarios los quechuahablantes
reclaman que se le dé a la lengua más
espacio en las instituciones
y se cumplen siete años de la
desaparición forzada en iguala en el
estado mexicano de guerrero de los 43
estudiantes de la normal de ayotzinapa
este año el aniversario coincide con la
revelación de un informe de la fiscalía
especial para el caso que señala que el
gobierno del entonces presidente enrique
peña nieto- habría utilizado tortura y
otros mecanismos ilegales para obtener
un respaldo para su versión de los
hechos en la denominada verdad histórica
según la cual los estudiantes habían
sido detenidos el 26 de septiembre de
2014 por policías corruptos y entregados
al cartel guerreros unidos que los
asesinó y lanzó sus restos en el río san
juan una versión que fue desmentida
luego de que los investigadores
designados por el actual presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador
identificaron los restos de dos de los
estudiantes en otro lugar con ayuda de
la universidad austriaca de innsbruck la
nueva unidad especial tiene una
hipótesis de lo que ocurrió en la noche
del 26 al 27 de septiembre de 2000
pero todavía trabaja en verificar la
esto es lo que se conoce hasta ahora
un grupo de estudiantes hizo lo mismo
que muchos normalistas hacen cada año
tomar autobuses en la central de
transportes de iguala para viajar a
ciudad de mexico y participar en los
actos en memoria de la matanza
estudiantil de 1968 una práctica común
pero fueron víctimas de un ataque de la
policía y el crimen organizado tres
estudiantes murieron otras tres personas
que no eran alumnos también perdieron la
vida un total de 57 personas
desaparecieron
el 27 de septiembre de 2014 la fiscalía
de guerrero concluyó que los policías
fueron los que le dispararon a los
estudiantes 22 oficiales de iguala
fueron detenidos el hallazgo de cuerpos
en fosas desata la tensión la fiscalía
estatal de guerrero afirma que los
policías municipales detuvieron a los
jóvenes y los entregaron a un grupo
narcotraficante guerreros unidos
normalistas de ayotzinapa y otros más de
michoacán incendiaron la casa del
gobernador de guerrero el gobierno
federal toma el control y envía al
ejército
el 15 de octubre de 2014 los estudiantes
de todo el país se manifiestan para
pedir justicia y dos días después una
marea de gente se toma el balneario más
famoso de guerrero acapulco liderado por
los padres de las víctimas las protestas
llegan hasta la ciudad de mexico hemos
advertido
los movimientos de violencia que al
amparo y al escudo de esta pena
pretenden hacer valer protestas
protestas que a veces no está claro su
objetivo
pareciera que respondían a un interés de
generar desestabilización
de generar
desorden social y sobre todo de atentar
contra el proyecto de nación que hemos
venido impulsando el gobernador ángel
aguirre renuncia ante la presión social
el 7 de noviembre de 2014 el entonces
fiscal general jesús murillo karam
informa el hallazgo de restos calcinados
de personas jóvenes se trata de los 43
estudiantes secuestrados y desaparecidos
en iguala el 26 de septiembre
tenemos
en enero de 2015 el gobierno presenta la
supuesta la verdad histórica según la
cual los estudiantes habían sido
secuestrados asesinados e incinerados
por integrantes del cartel guerreros
unidos
en 2018 el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador crea la comisión para la
verdad con el fin de apoyar a las
familias de las víctimas que
pronto
conozcamos la verdad se haga justicia
y se ponga un ejemplo para que nunca más
se violen derechos humanos en nuestro
país y es en junio de 2021 cuando se
acaba la verdad histórica con el
hallazgo de los restos de ellos iván y
guerrero uno de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa desaparecidos en 2014 lejos
del basurero donde los ubicaba la
versión oficial
nuestra cifra de la semana
610 millones de dólares eso fue lo que
costó la elección anticipada convocada
por josh instruido un precio récord el
primer ministro liberal logró obtener
votos suficientes para mantenerse en el
cargo pero no para que su partido
consiguiera controlar el parlamento que
era lo que él buscaba lo que dejó al
país exactamente como estaba antes sus
oponentes de derecha y de izquierda
denuncian que las elecciones fueron una
pérdida de tiempo y de recursos en medio
de una pandemia
de regreso al punto de partida después
del día número 36 de campaña el desglose
de la cámara de los comunes de canadá ha
cambiado muy poco el primer ministro
georges instruido ha sido reelegido por
tercera vez consecutiva
sin embargo falló una vez más en ganar
la mayoría de escaños
ayer you when you said los entiendo
cuando dicen que solo quieren volver a
hacer lo que les gusta no preocuparse
por esta pandemia o por unas elecciones
que sólo quieren saber que son miembros
del parlamento de todo tipo quienes lo
respaldarán en esta crisis y más allá
violant en agosto del 2021 todo y el
partido liberal de canadá se encontraban
en un auge de popularidad impulsado por
los programas de ayuda federal del cob y
aunque su segundo mandato pudo haber
durado hasta 2023 el primer ministro
canadiense decidió arriesgarse y propuso
elecciones anticipadas detrás de su
apuesta intentaron recuperar la mayoría
que perdió en 2019
después de dos grandes escándalos fotos
de él con su cara pintada de color negro
y un ex fiscal general acusando la
oficina del primer ministro de ejercer
presión sobre un caso de corrupción
desde entonces los liberales han tenido
que cooperar con partidos pequeños para
pasar la legislación
a pesar de un precio récord para de las
elecciones de 2021 de 610 millones de
dólares una encuesta reveló que tres
cuartas partes de los canadienses
pensaban que era innecesario
en cuanto a las políticas de
reconciliación con las comunidades
indígenas los liberales dicen que
enfrentarán el legado de las escuelas
residenciales sin embargo los líderes
indígenas advirtieron que el cob el 19 y
sus consecuencias económicas han
desviado la atención de su lucha
[Música]
y vamos a perú porque un discurso en
quechua del primer ministro guido
bellido en el congreso reactivo una
antigua polémica el maltrato y la
discriminación hacia los pueblos
originarios que se comunican en el
idioma de los incas diversos colectivos
critican que a pesar de ser una lengua
oficial no se le otorga el espacio que
merece en el parlamento nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
nos cuenta más en el siguiente reportaje
de hecho hace mi pie castellano sin
éxito
que no sea tan largo de exposición
porque además
muchos congresistas consideran que el
primer ministro ido bellido usó el
quechua para desafiar a un parlamento
que habla español eso lo que simplemente
hacer un show para llamar la atención y
extraer el fondo del problema pues de
una pose política no de populismo hacia
el sector de gente que considera que lo
sigue pero se equivoca él debe
comportarse a la altura del cargo que
tiene que no lo está haciendo en este
país más de 3 millones de personas han
reconocido al quechua como su lengua
materna representan un 13.6 por ciento
de los peruanos
una población que se siente marginada y
poco representada en el congreso ha sido
una oportunidad para que los quechuas
nos demos cuenta que que bueno hay que
decir con voz alta y fuerte que todavía
existimos y somos pueblos y culturas
vivas no somos folklore ni el pasado los
indígenas reclaman respeto y mejores
políticas de inclusión es vimos hores es
un artesano andino que se hace 12 años
al igual que muchos su familia ha
sufrido discriminación cuando llegó a
lima han dicho por qué no se prolonga su
pueblo que hacen aquí
pero como le digo ellos con su arte han
podido más sobresalir y tratar de que no
les choque mucho esa discriminación o
entonces han podido sobresalir
edwin espera que sus compatriotas
aprendan a valorar la cultura de sus
ancestros sueña que se inspira a los
peruanos a ser más unidos y que así
logren la estabilidad que el país
necesita
y la cifra de usuarios de bitcoin en
argentina aumentó un 6% en 2020 de
acuerdo con la revista especializada
forbes se trata de un aumento de 4 veces
respecto a 2019 los expertos dicen que
se debe a varios factores entre ellos la
volatilidad del peso la inflación y
hasta los subsidios a la electricidad
que la hacen más atractiva
cada día más argentinos compran cripto
monedas manuel es uno de ellos
bitcoin éter bien vi compra pequeñas
cantidades de cada una cada vez que
logra ahorrar algunos pesos
en el 96 este billete valía 100 pesos
hoy vale 18 mil yo no puedo tener los
pesos trabajo del colchón porque el
poder de compra de esa moneda desaparece
la confianza en el país es muy baja a
pesar de que muchas son usadas para
ahorrar las cripto monedas también están
circulando como moneda oficial son
aceptadas por ejemplo en esta barbería
hipster y en otros 200 negocios en el
país y el confinamiento aceleró este
proceso empezamos a hacer venta de pre
turnos y surge a partir la pregunta a
los clientes que tenían cripto monedas
como pueden hacer para abonar y si
podían utilizarla ya que muchos cobraban
a través de las diferentes plataformas
en que hablar es además otra forma de
esquivar los impuestos y las leyes
argentinas que impactan las
transacciones internacionales todo con
un solo clic los enchufás así con esto
quizá la placa madre la toma
es una oportunidad para empezar un
pequeño negocio en un país que una vez
más cayó en recesión
como consecuencia de los subsidios del
gobierno a la electricidad que la hacen
más barata el proceso de minería de
datos es muy rentable
es una manera de emprender es una manera
de crecer económicamente y en un país
donde faltan oportunidades esto es una
gran oportunidad los argentinos están
acostumbrados a las crisis económicas
así que otros retos inherentes de lo que
podría ser otra burbuja financiera no
asustan tanto a mauro ni a manuel ni a
otros argentinos apasionados del bitcoin
el futuro dirá si tenían razón y sigamos
en argentina para finalizar más de 400
parejas de 25 países participan en el
campeonato mundial de tango
[Música]
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas hoy natalia cabrera
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo giovanni agudelo sigan
con más en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]